oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
mom
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
so
obviously
foreign
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
so
i'd like to see
[Music]
so
good morning
apologize for getting started late
first day back from thanksgiving so
i hope everyone had a good thanksgiving
weekend
i want to talk to you today about where
we stand on the recount
lawsuits and the upcoming elections on
december 1st
and january 5th the truth matters
especially around election
administration
so the recount is going on scheduled to
be completed by our site
a wednesday date at mid at the midnight
deadline
once that is complete our office
continuing our work
to be transparent as possible we'll be
releasing
the recount results online as quickly as
possible
is the great thing about our paper
ballot system it is auditable
it is recountable and can provide voters
the confidence that the outcomes are
correct
once this recount is complete everyone
in georgia
will be able to have even more
confidence in the results of our
elections
despite the massive amounts of
misinformation
that is being spread by dishonest actors
there are those who are exploiting the
emotions of many trump supporters
with fantastic claims half truths
misinformation and frankly they are
misleading the president
as well apparently there are two suits
in federal court right now one was
already shot down
and is being appealed the other is just
beginning that is the due process
afforded to
us all of us as americans
as we move forward in the process we
will as we always have been
we will continue to investigate credible
claims of illegal voting and violation
of state
election law there are currently over
250 open cases
from 2020 and we have 23 investigators
that to follow up on them some of these
include
a charge in gwinnett county that
absentee ballots outnumber
absolutely envelopes this is the kind of
specific
charge that our office can investigate
and ascertain the truce
we have multiple investigations underway
surrounding city ballot
fulton gwinnett cobb
and many others we continue our
investigations into potential
dead double voters and non-resident
voters
as we move to the december 1st election
which is tomorrow
and the january 5th federal runoffs we
have to remain
vigilant that is why i'm announcing an
investigation into third
party groups working to register people
in other states
to vote here in georgia we have opened
an investigation into a group called
america votes who is sending absolutely
ballot applications to people
at addresses where they have not lived
since 1994.
vote forward who attempted to register a
dead alabama
voter a woman to vote here in georgia
the new georgia project who sent voter
registration applications to new york
city
and operation new voter registration
georgia
who is telling college students in
georgia that they can change their
residency to georgia
and then change it back after the
election
let me be very clear again voting in
georgia when you are not a resident of
georgia is a felony
and encouraging college kids to commit
felonies
with no regard for what might mean for
them is despicable
these third-party groups have a
responsibility to not encourage
illegal voting if they do so they will
be held
responsible let me emphasize this again
casting an illegal vote in georgia is a
felony
casting more than one vote in georgia is
a felony
in one election obviously this office
will continue to take
steps to protect the voting rights of
the legally registered georgians
of this state republican democrat
independent and whatever other party you
may be a member of
and whoever you align with upholding the
law
matters truth matters and your vote
matters
anyone telling you to boycott an
election
is not on your side your road
your right to vote is sacred don't let
someone con you out of it
everyone in my office is doing their job
we'll continue to follow them all
and we will continue to follow the
process thank you very much
hi guys glad to be back out of covid
quarantine and see all y'all in person
again
um just basically wanted to go over a
couple of extra things
because we are moving on obviously out
of the recount process soon
the enr page will likely be launched
today um
we're working with the counties right
now to make sure that it's done properly
so people will see that because
this recount result will be the
certified result which may require
having a few counties recertified and
that's the case and the stance
recertified just the presidential zone
is going to change on that so we're
having to go through
the efforts on that um another thing is
if we look at
january 5th beginning
[Music]
we're at 940 000 absentee ballots
we'll be part of that process so far um
included in that total is about 84 000
they're still on the elections dashboard
um for from the online
ballot application tool the counties
have to go through and verify they are
actually
the proper requestors um 1040 ballots
have already been accepted
voted and sent into the county so far
this small trickle we'll be expecting to
get a lot bigger soon
the um let's see
that's basically where we stand so any
questions you'll have right now
justin the secretary said 250
investigations
[Music]
unknown at this point because there are
250 of them until you dig into the
details of it you can't know for certain
there's nothing that has jumped off the
page at us is saying yes there's that
amount right now
like when that one's very specific if
there's more ballots than there are
envelopes that's obviously
an issue but we don't have any idea if
that delta even exists let alone the
amount of that delta yet
um a board member uh republican board
member filed affidavit stating that she
thinks from her observations that that
is the case so that that's the kind of
specific
charge with a specific person making a
specific you know charge that we can
binary go and do we can say yes this is
true
no this is not true it's it's better
than the sort of generalized thing we
see in many of these which is like
we think there's lots of issues and you
need to look at that it's very hard to
then
investigate that but a specific charge
that can be looked at in a binary way
either is or it isn't that's the kind of
thing
we're built to try to do or if you can
get even a specific
issue around we believe this person did
something wrong or this county does
something wrong on these days
there's things we have to have a
generalized let's let's look at all
again
i saw twitter's not exactly the best
place to have these kind of discussions
but somebody said
you know what i don't i don't believe we
i think we need to go back and recheck
all the voter id's again
for all the in-person votes to make sure
those are okay i mean you can't
follow up a lot of these things in a
real way like that
[Music]
this is yes forward right now this is
new information we've received
of these outside groups attempting to
register people illegally potentially
in other states that's for the january
5th election yes
secretary specifically
[Music]
if the person is actually establishing
residency but as we discussed the way
that these people are presenting it to
him like hey you can switch your
residency here and switch it back after
the election they're literally saying
hey it's okay to commit a felony
if they chose to be here after the fact
obviously because it's really part of a
state of mind
but if they're going into being sold hey
you can do this just to do this purpose
and switch it back right after
that's it's very specific that is
literally the definition of the felony
we're discussing
what else we got yes
here's the thing there were no dominion
issues in fulton county there was a
dominion server that crashed because
because fulton county literally ignored
the basic instructions
and the direct of the directions of the
vendor on this one
they were given a what is called an
express server to do lna which is a lot
of
accuracy testing on the machines they're
going to be using for the election
tomorrow basically and they instead
decided to hey we're going to use this
for the recount
when they should have been using their
central server so what happened was they
built the first cards out of their
central servers
this is going to get deep in the weeds
and i apologize for that so they built
i think it was seven cards i'm not
exactly positive and they were intended
for
absentee by mail scam you have to set up
each one of the tabulators differently
in order to keep the buckets straight of
the different four different types of
ballots let's go through those again
there's election day ballots provisional
ballots um early voting which is
absentee in person
and then they have something by mail
battles there's four basic buckets so
that's the tabulars they have to do
so what they did kind of cutting a
corner
they first their intention was we're
going to use the express
server as the one we upload all the
stuff into and
there was a dominion employee there says
you can't do that
because it will crash that server so
they said okay well we're going to put
the database on here and we're going to
tabulators off of this
but then they didn't follow procedure
and did not back up that thing actually
back they did back it up they did it on
the same drive
so when the server that server crashed
that computer crashed it's really just a
computer like this
it's just a simple laptop computer and
it crashed
so they could not get that database off
because once you make the tabulator on
the new database
the timestamp is different than the
original database you had so you can't
then upload it because that's a security
measure
because you don't want to have something
that wasn't created the right in the
right place they can then upload into
your existing election project
so again fulton county with one
particular technician
ignored the direct directives of our
office ignored
the the opinion and directions from the
vendor and caused this situation by
ignoring that and choosing to go their
own path even though they were told
don't do that so now they're going to be
forced to rescan balance
it has nothing to do with servers being
wiped nobody directed that
that's just a lie it's made up out of
whole cloth and it's the kind of stuff
we're having to deal with
so that's the situation we're in right
now but that's what really happened does
that give you a better clarification as
to what happened
it won't impact the results there's more
work and more man-hours and more time
which is the kind of thing that you
often find when you cut corners you end
up adding cost and time because you cut
corners and that's what happened in this
case in fulton county which
every other county managed to pull this
off pretty well fulton county on this
one particular thing
didn't get it right because one
technician was there and then they
compounded the error
by sitting there for four hours
yesterday and not explaining to the
press
and to the observers there what was
happening which led to rampant
speculation
and where we get some of these lies
about the secretary ordering servers to
be wiped because it's just not true
all right yes sir
not question to move to georgia some
people are here and the other ones
they're
literally sending it to people in other
states to register here
they they tried to say there's a
registration stuff to a dead woman in
alabama
i mean so things there are specific we
have specific evidence which is what
i've repeatedly said at this podium
if they'll off the office get specific
evidence to follow up on we will follow
up on it
is it possible
i'm going to assume they're all going to
stay as privileged as an accident but
that's why you investigate
you got to see what the underlying thing
was and the specific one where they're
saying hey you can switch your
registration back
that shows intent which is a little bit
different a little higher standard
i do not know the answer that question
but that's why you investigate
yes ma'am
i have confidence will all be done by
wednesday at midnight that it is 2020 so
i'm never going to say yeah we know
what's going to happen but we're pretty
sure it's going to happen
yeah president supporters
[Music]
um
given the sort of vulnerabilities that
occupiers
here's the reality again
there are people who are upset with the
outcome of an election dominion
let's start the full timeline again in
2019 the legislature passed a bill
that required bmd's ballot marketing
device to be the
machine of choice for the state
regardless of vendor
i think the day after the
um legislature passed it after both
houses passed it we released an rfp
that the office been working on
essentially since before the secretary
was sworn in
that rfp process followed the georgia
procurement law
and we worked in coordination with the
department of administrative services
there were three bidders
um there were potentially four um one
bidder heart inner civic
missed the deadline by i don't they
upload stuff they didn't hit the final
upload so they were they were cut off
out of the gate
then you had esns which was the
incumbent vendor who had taken over the
old dive ball machines
you had dominion and then you had
another one called smartmatic
that partnered with another company
that's named the skateboard now because
it's been over a year ago
so we went through a process and they
were scored there was 32
main questions and i want to say there's
something like 200 of 250 so sub
questions from that they were all scored
by a group of individuals there were
seven people on the committee
and they were not just secretary of
state in fact i think there was only two
from secretary of state's office
but we had a disability advocate there
we had two elections directors on there
we had um you know a security expert
from
the um what do you call it the georgia
technology authority
so we had a multi-faceted group of
people doing these evaluations
um so all three people did their written
bids then all three of them came in and
did
in-person demonstrations from those the
initial scoring came in the esn s was
number one in technical
but they were bad on pricing and
dominion was best on on pricing and just
a little behind ess on technical
so then we moved into a negotiation
phrase with both esns and dominion
and there's a lot of security questions
throughout all the
of this thing and so everybody answers
those things equally and we
put price down at only 25 of the
overall amount so that was only part of
it and it was a smaller part
we were trying to say what are you
balancing off on this for the taxpayers
versus what you're getting on the value
side
so at the end of the day they had their
initial bids and all of this is
available on the department of
administrative services website
it's all public and transparent you can
see the initial bids you can see that
the contract
it's all there and black and white has
been there since we signed the contract
which was in the summer of 2019.
so dominion both ess and dominion
lowered their prices a lot so we did a
good job protecting the taxpayers on
that front
uh but dominion still came out ahead so
dominion
following our procurement law was the
one that was chosen and if you remember
the time there was a lot of
some of these same people who are
complaining now are complaining that oh
if the
the bid is being rigged for esns because
there are people who came to knew who
used to do that even though kemp's
office had zero to do with this
none zero nada zilch so
we chose dominion we executed the
contract and we started doing something
that nobody said we could do we got all
the equipment out
from the from the initial order by
valentine's day of 2020. that was our
first big lift that we did
so we got those out the door and the
dominion system
anything with a computer has critical
vulnerabilities the ridiculous
things claim that some of these lawsuits
are just that their
insanity is fever dream made up
internet cabal i can't however many
words i can do to say how crazy some of
these things are
nothing was shipped overseas no no votes
for switch
we did a hand audit that proved no votes
were switched i mean
that in and of itself should have been
enough to make people understand that so
the idea that there was a machine
flipping votes didn't happen so once
that's out of the way then they shift
gears on some of these things
to talk about the system itself but
there's no
no proof of dominion system having any
flaws like that um
the situation in texas that some people
have related back to this
was they literally had a light they
wanted to plug in
to a u.s open usb port so a voter could
press a button to ask for help
and i said well it's an open usb port
that's a security risk we don't have
that issue in ours because we don't have
that
all of our stuff is sealed and taped in
and
not accessible on those fronts
i said the other day it's like playing a
game of whack-a-mole
every time we knock down one there's a
new crazier one
so we are doing our best to be
transparent and answer all these charges
because there are people out there
who people respect and are believing
some of these things
and it's difficult and it's frustrating
and i'm sure y'all and then can see that
from my own tone of voice on this but
doug does that kind of get you to the
answer
he did he said to me in security
[Music]
you can mitigate all these things it's
always going to be that way because if
let's say we go to
the luddite version and you do hand
marked
hand paper hand counting we wouldn't
have we would still be counting
it's it's in the same thing we're a
nation of 300 million people
and you have to have systems in place
and actually these systems provide extra
guard rails and extra checks
to to make sure that everything is being
done properly imagine
it's going to your bank and saying i
only want to do things with checks and
cash now
you couldn't do it i mean we don't live
in that kind of society
and there's nobody shown any actual real
vulnerabilities that have ever been
exploited
and i'll quote chris krebs said this is
the most secure election in the history
united states and i can guarantee this
is the most secure election in the
history of the state of georgia
are there going to be bad actors are
there going to be mistakes
are there going to be people who try to
exploit issues sometimes absolutely
that's why we investigate double voters
that's why we investigate potentially
dead voters that's why we investigate
people trying to illegally register
things
but nearly every single one of those has
zero to do with the system
and 100 to do with individuals trying to
gain the system
and it always comes down to that
what else yeah
[Music]
didn't say moved to georgia again what i
said was there are people outside of
georgia they were trying to register
and or people who are in here who are
temporary
residents who are trying to say hey you
can vote this way and then flip back and
that's where you get to the intent of
you're really trying to gain the system
at that point
so we're not saying they're trying to
encourage people to vote here there was
a lot of twitter activity and we've seen
some internet other
move to georgia and votes we do know
that exists too we're trying to track
that down as well but
these four specific ones had more to do
with trying to register
people illegally directly right
i didn't the secretary did
and at specific one they sent voter
registration forms to individuals in new
york city
and obviously not living here
what else anybody all right well thanks
guys i'll watch you later
glad to be back